we're taking a closer look this morning
at one moment of remarkable selflessness
during the Las Vegas attack this image
seen around the world captured two
people who met at the festival fighting
to get to safety as the gunmen fired on
them only on CBS this morning DeMarco
Morgan has the story behind the
incredible photo he is in Las Vegas
DeMarco good morning good morning George
cook and Larissa Loy were already
connected by their love of music do I
get on the ground you know jump out am i
chairing it on the ground or stay on my
chair I chose to stay in the chair
that's when Larissa came to me to my
right and said hi George I'm making his
mom I'm gonna get you out of here nearly
four days after they were targeted
George cook and Larissa Loy are talking
about this now iconic photo of their
daring escape I see that picture and I'm
like oh my god gunshots were fired I'm
standing up straight well it's flying
and you're saving people yeah that kind
of freaked me out a little bit I can't
lie that did but it's okay it's all for
the greater good right as hundreds of
bullets darted past Lena she tried to
find cook a path to safety there's no
way he could maneuver himself through
this there was rubbish everywhere you
know beer cans and trash all sort of
stuff was on the ground but you know we
can we were able to push through that
the ICU nurse said Las Vegas Sunrise
Hospital suffered only a sprained ankle
but some wounds run deeper at night when
you're sleeping you just can't get the
gunshots out of your head my daughter
she saw a man die it's a lot to take in
back home in San Francisco with his 11
year old daughter and 13 year old son
Cook says a selfless act was heaven-sent
I'm a single dad with two kids at home
so this is real important I'm alive
maybe that's why this happens and maybe
that's why this person was sent to save
me is to be there for the kids
the two have exchanged numbers and they
plan to keep in touch
gal DeMarco thank you